Um, okay, let's go to the color from the two
62 area code caller from two, six, two.
Uh, who are you?
Where are you calling?
I'm Zachary [inaudible].
I'm a philosopher.
Stanford.
Great.
And we're not on speaker phone or we, no.
Okay.
And what, whatever's on in the background,
if you are able to turn it down, it would
be really great.
Yes.
It's the same.
Yeah.
All right.
Well, what's going on, Zachary?
Um, so I wanted, my friends are right wing
and I try and tell them that I support Bernie
Sanders and they always seem to think that
I support comedies and I always play the videos
that they clips of independent news.
And that was the, Oh, you would just watch
to get that.
And I've never claimed anything.
Your Netflix, nothing of the soil.
I don't know what to do here cause I always
think that Bernie Sanders with the communist
store,
well I would just ask them if they're making
the assert.
So, you know, I would point out communism
is state control of industry, right?
I mean communism has a very, very, the state
controls the means of production.
Um, can you give me one example of a communist
policy from Bernie Sanders and just put it
on them?
You know, I mean honestly it sounds like you
really shouldn't even be talking politics
with these people.
Sounds like an exercise in frustration.
Uh, yeah, the Goto is a single payer healthcare
and I say that's not, that's like a social
democracy thing.
That's not a social, that communism,
no.
I mean if they say that, I would say, is Denmark
a communist country?
Is Sweden a communist country up there?
And then they say, look at the size of the
country though, compared to us.
Well, but that's, so then they're moving the
goalpost.
Then you have to point out, you are moving
from an argument about whether single payer
is communism to an argument about whether
single payer can work in a country of 300
million million people like the United States.
They've moved the goalpost and you've got
to point that out right away.
Yes.
Yep.
Thank you.
All right, no problem.
Uh, yeah, those conversations.
I try not to have those conversations because
they're, you know, as you can tell, pretty
problematic.